[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today let's go
to Victor who joins us now in Hartford
Connecticut Victor how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call sure
um my wife and I we got married about uh
eight years ago and we're really good at
saving but uh not very good at investing
I guess so apparently we have about 250
000 in savings and
um we thought we'd splurge on a on a new
car and we got a car loan for about 59
000. and the loan is for five years five
years uh five at five percent Victor how
long do you want to listen to this show
um I've discovered you about uh I guess
two years ago but I don't listen
regularly all right Victor do you know
what our position is on on taking out
loans for anything much less a car
uh don't do it don't do it and my friend
you've got the 250 in the bank but no
but no because I'm shook to my core that
you have you're spending sixty thousand
dollars on a car I just need to know
your income and maybe my shook shook it
nature will go away but tell me how much
your income is
uh well it's it's grown substantially in
uh recent years but uh this year we're
on track to make about uh uh 175. no
okay 175 combined yeah
I
thought what's your wife's car worth
um the the worth of the cars I believe
um what'd you pay yeah what'd you pay
for it
64. no just over 64. you guys are
tripping you're tripping slipping and
dipping you got it 60 000 260 000 cars
this is the the car that we got
this is just the new purchase and do you
have any other debt I know but I want to
know how many cars they have and what
they're worth total all right so so
answer Jade's question because she says
you're tripping slipping and dipping I
think that's how that went that is
correct uh what is what is the other car
that you have and we know it's paid for
um
uh we have a
roughly fifteen thousand dollar car okay
okay so the sixty thousand dollar the
sixty thousand dollar car and the
fifteen thousand dollar car that's
seventy five thousand dollars I know I
know it costs I know it's high but they
got the cash so before I even get to
that part I'm like why would you take
out a loan for a car and Jade's gonna
get you to this is the kind of car you
should be buying based on the ratios but
why in the world before we get to that
why would you take out a loan when you
have no other debt and you got all kinds
of cash in the bank
I want to understand your philosophy
I don't think it's a it's I mean I don't
know if it's a good philosophy or not
but um we um our bank where we uh keep
our savings approached us uh with an
offer to invest in a
um brokerage account so I don't know if
a brokerage account with stats gonna net
us more uh Revenue to
offset the the percentage on the on the
car alone that was your that was your
reasoning
yes okay yeah no it makes no sense to me
what he's thinking is he's like well
it's five percent online nobody's
thinking he's looking at the percentages
of Interest instead of real dollars yeah
which is a car payment of what what's
your car payment on this thing
uh well real dollars the real cost of
the loan is going to be 8 000 over five
years
that's not what I asked you so you're
already playing games yeah you're
playing oh no okay what is your car
payment
per month it's going to be around 11
1100. that is just mind-numbingly stupid
yeah it's so much money it's just so
much money and here's the thing you
don't have to play these games you know
you're making 175 000 you're both
working you can pay for things in cash
this car I'm guessing was brand brand
spanking new right
correct very much you're already upside
down yeah how much could you have saved
by just getting a year used a two years
used right probably twenty thousand
dollars
like this it's not worth it for me I
have a feeling that you're gonna do what
you want to do because this your game
makes sense to you and that's that's
okay
um I would tell you to sell this car I I
think it's it's I think it's extravagant
for where you're at
um
you could pay it off in two seconds and
keep it I'm not mad at you if you did I
think you have way too much money in
savings
um you said it was savings but then you
said it was a brokerage account so I
want to make sure is it invested money
no no it's not invested yet um that's
that's why I'm calling to ask see if
it's a good idea to go into a brokerage
account no oh yeah that kind of money
okay so I'm just gonna briefly and this
is not just for you for anyone listening
here's how we teach it's it's a series
of steps and I think that if you filter
it through this it's going to help you
all right in your case do you have any
other debt besides these cars I put him
on hold I thought you were running
that's okay that's okay if you have any
other debt besides these cars we would
take any money that you have saved less
a thousand dollars and throw it at your
debt so in your case we'd pay off every
single penny of debt that's baby step
two by the way he has no other debt but
this new car sweet yeah pay it off and
then you've got plenty of money we would
keep three to six months of expenses set
aside you could keep it in a high yield
savings account but not non-invested
money that you can it's liquid you can
get to it easily that's baby step three
baby step four is we would start
investing fifteen percent of your income
every month into either your 401k or a
Roth IRA okay that's next then you know
you could say first your kids college if
you wanted to and then you would use any
money left over that you just had cash
sitting around or that's in your income
you can throw that at your home mortgage
to pay it off early so you've got a lot
of money sitting around
um some of it is your three to six month
emergency fund to be liquid some of it's
going to go to pay off this car and then
what whatever it's left if you have a
mortgage due throw it at your mortgage I
don't think I'm going to be able to
convince you to do that because our
minds work in different ways
um but that's really the way to do it
that's the fastest
safest most secure way to build wealth
and I'm not just saying that as a
talking head we've done the studies
it's true millions of people have done
it this way so that's all I can tell you
and that's all I'm going to tell you